[Musique]
ça ce sont les ray-ban stories qui sont
faites en partenariat avec facebook et
vous voyez là c'est que je suis en train
d'enregistrer donc ça c'est pratique le
problème c'est la résolution qui est pas
dingue ici j'aurais aimé avoir la 4k
c'est un format peu particulier je vais
tout vous expliquer on va regarder ça
ensemble
[Musique]
aussi un truc que j'aime bien c'est les
lunettes ray ban alors je porte soit
normalement sont bonnes avec des petites
finitions rouge et les indiens et quand
on m'a proposé de venir essayer nouvelle
lune est connecté de ray-ban fait en
partenariat avec facebook et ben sénat
plutôt branché
sur là dedans normalement ferry bastos
s'est regardé soit ça qui packaging qui
pourtant sympa hop ça marche vous les
avez dedans il ya une application nous
indique ici pour venir installer ok
alors c'est fourni avec un petit câble
en ici pour venir recharger onu sbc vous
avez ensuite un étui qui plutôt sympa
avec votre prise derrière ici on use
baisser pour revenir de recharger avec
un petit connecteur la la voyez juste
ici pour venir charger vos lunettes et
puis ensuite vous avez vos lunettes les
lunettes en elle-même horse et des ray
ban en cd wife erreur si vous connaissez
le modèle c'est le plus grand modèle le
plus grands standards de cherré bal avec
ici des petites caméras vous avez une
caméra là vous avez une deuxième caméra
c'est de caméra de 5 mégapixels alors
dans l'idée pourquoi pas ça vous sort
pas deux images vous avez vraiment une
image maintenant je sais pas comment est
ce qu ils font leurs petites sauces en
interne pour savoir laquelle va venir
filmer laquelle va venir shooter vous
avez un capteur de luminosité également
de fournir s'adapte à la lumière
environnante et c'est normal parce qu'on
est quand même ce sont des lunettes de
soleil alors entré je vais avoir de la
commande à la voix par exemple quand je
veux faire une photo avec facebook t'as
que photo voilà la photo est fait et
facebook oui corps de vidéos oui là je
suis en train d'enregistrer on voit le
peu de citoyens blancs quelques je suis
en train d'enregistrer donc le voile à
lhassa ces termes une fois de plus il
veut mais loin là est ce que vous le
voyez le petit noyau dur peut-être en
devine mais comme il ya beaucoup de
lumière c'est pas extrêmement évident et
facebook et facebook donc on capte plus
donc il va arrêter au bout de 30
secondes d'enregistrer directement donc
le truc aussi qu'un peu relou ici c'est
que vous ne pouvez lui parler en anglais
si vous lui posez les commandes en
france et ça marchera pas et facebook
prend une photo avec un dîner niang la
saison là il n'a pas compris vous
retrouvez ensuite sur l'intérieur juste
là la regarder je peux aussi vous le
verrez bien un petit bouton pour venir
les abîmes et donc là sont déjà allumé
la up vous poussez en arrière vous les
éteignez vous pousser là vous les
allumer vous avez une petite laide à
l'intérieur alors qu'il est juste là
pour vous et vous le verrez dans votre
champ de vision l'intérieur qui est
blanche lorsque vous l'allumez et puis
vous avez ici un petit pavé tactile vous
appuyer une fois vous lancez la musique
deux fois morceau suivant trois fois
morceaux précédents vous montez le son
vous baissez sont un petit appel via
messenger parce que oui c'est ici c'est
messenger deux fois vous décroché deux
fois je crois vous raccrochez bref tous
fait ici ça c'est plutôt sympa et puis
vous pouvez aussi écouter de la musique
avec spotify du coup ce sont des petits
des petits écouteurs c'est pas dingue
mais ça vous permet d'écouter de la
musique sans que personne le sache ou de
pouvoir converser donc l'idée est plutôt
sympa et je trouve en tout cas son
principe assez marrante
[Musique]
mais surtout ici ce sont des ouailles
fahrer ce sont des lunettes de ray-ban
ça veut dire quoi c'est bien vous avez
une vraie protection uv une vraie
protection des aires alors surtout
qu'ils font ça coûte 320 et quelques
euros pour 129 euros d'ailleurs si vous
intéresse je vous le moyen quelque part
en bas de la description et jeter un
coup d'oeil ces mutations vachement
intéressante parce qu'elle permette
effectivement devenir shooter de venir
faire des photos de venir faire des
vidéos pour les réseaux sociaux mais
uniquement pour les réseaux sociaux
c'est à dire que si vous voulez comme
moi par exemple pouvoir l'utiliser pour
venir et bien partir j'en sais rien moi
en vo et avoir une belle image en cas de
cas à 30 images par seconde en c'est pas
possible vous avez informé un peu bâtard
en 30 images par seconde mais bon voilà
autant les photos on peut faire des
choses autant et vidéo ça me paraît être
moins cool c'est vraiment fait pour les
réseaux sociaux s'est par contre y passe
et d'utilisation je dire faire une photo
je mets comme ça j'ai cette pluie
attention ça fait la photo je venais à
faire une vidéo j'ai pu une fois et j'ai
une vidéo cours de 30 secondes mais
surtout ses lunettes il vienne vraiment
soulever un poids qui est vachement
important c'est la question de la
confidentialité parce que si vous
revenez quelques années en arrière on
revient au niveau des google glace trop
sortir je sais plus combien d'années
c'était quand même un peu un gros bide
et moulins glh pourquoi et bien parce
qu'on avait un vrai gros problèmes de
confidentialité et j'en voyais arriver
quelqu'un avec des lunettes avec une
caméra pouvait filmer en permanence et
ça ça n'a pas trop plu à juste titre
pourquoi parce que lorsque vous êtes
j'en sais rien dans un bar avec des amis
que je trouve devant un coup sur quoi
que ce soit vous n'avez pas forcément
envie qu'on vienne vous regarde et qu'on
vienne vous filmez qu'on puisse venir
vous prendre en photo votre assumer pour
autant ces questions de confidentialité
sur le sein des places un peu le
problème parce que là effectivement tué
sur les troncs et lorsque je viens film
et j'appuie j'ai un petit voyant blanc
qui salue je sais pas si vous le voyez
alors je peux modifier dans
l'application et tout le monde en
quelques instants que je peux soit le
maître fort le maître moyen ou le met
bas âge peut pas couper c'est impossible
après prévenir avoir un petit hakim
était une petite couche de peinture
noire dessus on le verra plus donc ça
c'est possible mais bon c'est pas trop
lié du truc faut vraiment jouer l'idée
que je pense le montre à tout moment
faute extrêmement transparent dort
effectivement là on voit que c'est en
train de filmer ces pratiques si
j'arrête vous voyez ces plans très
intime et donc le taux qui est bien mais
bon ça peut quand même posé un problème
maintenant et si on va un peu plus loin
et pour devenir développer un peu
prendre de la confidentialité des
caméras y en a partout à commencer là
dessus c'est à dire que lorsque ce sera
mon smartphone et j'avais comme ça est
en train de vous parler vous voyez
peut-être pas mais je peux venir vos
films est donc quelque part la voir sans
la tronche ça déplace le problème mais
est-ce qu'on a tout le temps envie
d'avoir quelqu'un en face de soi qui a
une caméra on jouait ce qu'il est en
train de finir ce qui n'est pas en train
de me filmer pour moi c'est là vraiment
que se pose le problème que se pose la
question et ça vient vraiment soulever
des questions même je dirais deux
sociétés est ce qu'on a envie d'avoir
des caméras tout le temps avec nous est
ce qu il des caméras tout le temps avec
nous alors malchance un génial ça permet
de sortir des images que vous n'auriez
pas autrement briller comme ça on voit
il ya un côté qui est hyper immersif et
je peux le faire de la même manière avec
une gaufre autres venir poser leurs je
m'emmerdais un peu plus ça c'est clair
parce que là je peux répondre à un appel
je peux écouter de la musique mais voilà
en tout cas le débat est posé je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez que je compte
vraiment c'est qu'on est ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire parce que c'est
vraiment un sujet de société est ce
qu'on a envie d'avoir des caméras
partout tout le temps avec soin à être
moins envie d'être tout le temps filmer
ou alors pas du tout jour le problème de
confidentialité je suis comme ça je me
balade au regard des gens les films
personne ne le sait et c'est sûr que tu
vas quoi un mec avec des lunettes de
soleil et les gens au loin là je veux
dire que le point blanc il ne voit pas
donc le problème il soulève mais ça
dépendra de qui le portent les
l'intention de la personne et ça c'est
un problème de société que je pense pas
que ce soit en un problème de lunettes
mais qui ça vient accentuer le problème
plutôt qu'un problème d'individu et
d'utilisation très clairement ici mais
après je peux aussi utiliser des
lunettes pour venir vous parler utilisé
en caméra cela j'utilise mes lunettes
jeunes en face je leur parle ça il ya
même manière alors c'est pas trop de
buts en ce n'est pas une calais 1 c'est
vraiment pour la vue subjective mais bon
c'est vrai que c'est une question qui
est pas hyper évidente comme ça et qui
n'est pas facile à penser
[Musique]
regardez là mais de la musique j'aime
être à fond pas si vous entendez là
je monte le son je baisse comme ça comme
sur des buzz en fait un morceau suivant
ans au précédent trois fois c'est hyper
intuitif alors ça c'est vrai que sans
ses lunettes s'appelle tout ce qui peut
être un petit peu compliqué c'est que
c'est quand même vachement mastoc sur
ses plumes à stocker sur des wife erreur
un peu classique mais bon c'est par moi
j'aime bien le design
[Musique]
application les là c'est vieillot
facebook view alors hop garder jeu
louvre donc là j'ai quelques photos
alors je vous montre en fait vous
arrivez ici vous avez vos captures fait
par date ce qu'on fait c'est que vous
cliquez ici et là ça vient vous
connecter au réseau wifi donc là il peut
se connecter au réseau wi fi des
lunettes fait ok rejoint hélas en montre
le nombre de photos et de vidéos qu'il
est en train de télécharger pendant
qu'ils téléchargent de la sphère là j'ai
mes photos j'ai tout là j'ai des photos
je peux mettre enfin vous réussi à
retrouver extrêmement facilement ici il
me marc mon niveau de batterie sûr qu'il
me reste 1 29% sur mes lunettes ce clic
dessus au niveau des paramètres objets
quelques informations ici notamment sur
les lumières led de notification ça ne
fait que quelques petites infos c'est
très pratique ce qui va être réellement
intéressant dans cette application c'est
dans le menu général ici préférences en
matière de capture enregistrement
automatique d'une copie directement dans
l'application photos facebook assistance
à c'est aussi intéressant je viens
l'activé gk lui dire hey facebook et
puis voyez perdre et hop là il fera le
job et facebook je peut l'activer ou pas
sont notification hockey raccourci pour
les photos stop louis cording d'accord
faut vraiment connaître les mots clés
ici je lui ai dit il en train
d'enregistrer en train de parler dans
mes oreilles langues et voit donc là
j'ai langue uniquement états unis
royaume uni ou australie donc j'ai que
l'anglais j'ai pas du français pour
l'assistant et ça c'est quand même
vraiment dommage j'espère que ça
arrivera comme on l'est sur facebook
appels et messages passer forcément par
messenger mais si on vous recevez un
appel téléphonique ça marchera n'y a pas
de souci là-dessus danse ont évolué mais
vous avez le son directement peut
choisir faibles moyens élevés hockey a
l'air système des notifications push
également que vous pouvez venir recevoir
konsa y avait plus de stockage plus de
batterie températures basses et
compagnie ça c'est intéressant ça voyez
la led au niveau de la notification moi
je les mises en fait mais vous pouvez la
montée élevé si vous voulez vraiment que
les gens en face de vous s'en rendre
compte et la voix bon une fois de plus
ce lunettes de soleil vous êtes dehors
il ya beaucoup de soleil très clairement
les gens ne verront pas à mon avis sauf
s'ils sont vraiment très très près de
vous et puis à des assistances donc
voilà vous avez quelques petites
informations ici mais l'application elle
est assez sommaire mais dans l'idée
pourquoi pas pour trouver ensuite ici
vos photos garde et hop là j'ai une
photo là je peux créer un petit avantage
flash-back créé un clip depuis vos clips
et photos donc là je viens sélectionner
les différents plans j'ai quoi comme
plan là tiens par exemple j'aime mettre
ça me met ça met ça ça et ça hop là
suivant la salle mais la date voyez donc
la sam a généré un petit clip que je
peux dire partager sur les réseaux
sociaux à partir de photos avec des
humains ou d mme in et ça je trouve ça
tout ça c'est marrant et je peux venir
créer des flashbacks qui animait
capturés pour la rendre plus vivante fin
bref mal de petites options qu'on peut
venir mettre ici est bon dans l'idée
pourquoi pas il fait plus est pour
l'instant g la story partager tout dans
facebook dont bon c'est sympa
[Musique]
on va se regarder un petit peu les
différentes photos condamnés à le
regarder déjà un truc qu'on voit c'est
le poids des photos si vous regardez le
poids de chaque image on est quand même
un méga quelque 900 échec donc ça
fonctionne si je regarde la résolution
de chaque photo je suis à 2592 par 1944
hockey don pour venir partager voyez
c'est bien samuel marque la monnaie du
périphérique célébrer vannes stories
srgb bon ok ça ça fonctionne les photos
n'a même pas mal franchement est ce qui
est cool ans et une fois de plus voyez
on voit vraiment la main ça raconte une
histoire la caméra qui est en train de
filmer comme ça c'est pas mal même à
contre-jour ça c'est marrant tout ça
c'est assez rigolo c'est peut-être pas
le truc le plus parfait on n'est pas sur
un smartphone on aura un super capteurs
on est sur des capteurs de 5 mégapixels
donc c'est pas un truc de fou pour
retirer par quelques souvenirs à ramener
de l'instantané on a des choses qui sont
assez rigolote voyait là il a du mal par
exemple avec le contre-jour c'est assez
marrant ça c'est pour la partie photo et
si on veut regarder la partie vidéo et
bien regardez là j'ai un fichier qui
fait combien qui fait 1184 paramé 184
c'est un carré en fait donc ça peut être
mis sur instagram sur office a peut être
mis en oeuvre il ça peut être mis en pas
mal de choses c'est pas un format qui
est parfait mais moment voilà de venir
partager une fois de plus sur des
réseaux sociaux on peut réussir à faire
un truc alors c'est pas mal la qualité
est sympa c'est rigolo peut mieux faire
j'aimerais bien qu'une version 2 où on
puisse vraiment filmé en 4k 30fps avoir
des meilleurs capteurs ça serait
vraiment bien c'est vraiment dans le
sens de l'histoire pour réussir à se
mettre au niveau d'un smartphone ça
serait un peu le but parce que ça c'est
sympa c'est un beau gadget c'est des
belles lunettes de soleil connectés mais
assez pour moi parce que massu créateurs
de contenu donc je veux toujours plus
mais bon comme ça déjà c'est exprès mais
c'est quand même plutôt pas mal
[Musique]
voilà pour ce que ça va vous raconter
aujourd'hui sur ses lunettes de ray-ban
lunettes ray ban wayfarer facebook et
ben and stories story c'est marrant
d'ailleurs sincèrement penser aux
lunettes de snapshot pour pour autant
c'est parfaitement partenaires avec ray
ban les leçons ça c'est cool je sais pas
ce que vous en pensez vous comment vous
trouvez le 10 sport est ce que vous
trouvez intéressant ce modèle de
lunettes de soleil pour venir utiliser
facilement partout tout le temps partagé
sur les réseaux faut-il partager tout le
temps sur les réseaux faut-il des
caméras sur bonus un très large débat
vous invite à lire ce que vous en pensez
juste en bas en commentaire nous on
continuera sa puis moi je verrais tu es
sûr que tu as tant d'autres photos que
j'ai partagé sur les différents réseaux
que ce soit un film où que ce soit à tik
tok ce soit un style un parce que ces
photos vous pouvez les récupérer les
mettre directement dans votre
application photo et après vous les
mettez vous voulez vous n'êtes pas
obligé les met sur facebook et ça c'est
cool voilà s'embrasse on les soigne
après midi
[Musique]